one
and you're live chairman thank you
good afternoon and welcome to this joint
standards committee meeting
on tuesday the 26th of january 2021
my name is councillor mark bassinger and
i am the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
on the 4th of april in response to the
covet 19 pandemic
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
camera remains
on where broadband permits and your
microphone
remains muted when not addressing the
committee
[Music]
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded by being present in this
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
okay man can you just pause for a second
and check if everybody has their
microphones muted
please
thank you chairman i think that's fine
now
thank you i shall continue members and
officers
during each item please use the hands up
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating a wish to
indep apart members are reminded that
apart
from indicating a wish to raise a point
of order
that you have that you have to leave the
meeting the meet
please do not use the chat function
members when speaking and referring to
the gender papers
please reference a page or paragraph
number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise
as possible when invited to speak
please ensure you turn on your
microphone
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with mr hudson
and mr hudson your microphone is muted
good afternoon councillors it's norman
hodgson the independent person
good afternoon miss todderson uh mr
quelch
yes good afternoon everyone it's simon
quelch um i'm what's called the
monitoring officer for the council
good afternoon mr clutch berna
good afternoon members good afternoon
chairman bernie kc
clark to the committee thank you thank
you
any other officers present
okay before i call on the clerk for the
roll call of committee members
can i ask those counsellors in
attendance to introduce themselves
please
counselor mark heard chairman of the
council
good lady mark what's up
penny channel good afternoon
good afternoon it's peter stilts i'm a
morgan town councillor i'm here as a
non-voting
member
sorry chairman we're just asking those
members in attendance so i believe
councillor lagan is also in attendance
if he could introduce himself please
okay shall i move to the royal call of
uh committee members chairman
yes please berna thank you
members i will call your names in
alphabetical order
starting with councillor bassinger
i'm president thank you berna thank you
council boys
yeah thank you councillor fleming
president thank you ben um
thank you now mays
president good afternoon
good afternoon thank you counselor peter
stilts
food burner uh good afternoon i'm here
thank you cancer thompson
good afternoon yes i'm here at apologies
chairman i was not very much on the last
minute
thank you members thank you chairman
thank you berna um so
where are we there we are
okay uh item number two please apologize
berna
do we have any we've received no
apologies for abstinence chairman thank
you
thank you i should go to item three
which is the minutes
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 27th of october
2020 found on pages 5
and 10 are approved as a true and
accurate record iso move
if you wish to second that motion please
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
if any member wishes to raise any matter
of accuracy
please use the hands up function to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
secondary counselors
do we have those minutes noted or
well chairman if nobody has um any
dissent or any
matters of accuracy we can agree them by
ascent
and nobody has asked to speak no
chairman agreed thank you thank you
members can we agree those minutes by
ascent
yes yes agreed yes
okay thank you moving on to item number
four
declarations of interest to disclose
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose
any such interest as soon as they become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
thank you very much and i can see that
counselor none please
thank you very much chairman um i'll
take direction from you
chair and from mr quelch but i didn't
know whether to disclose at this point
or
under item six stroke seven but i am
acquainted with
two of the applicants uh could i have
direction about
whether i disclose now and name that
acquaintance like those acquaintances or
or what do i do please
thank you council and uh mr quelch could
you please advise please
yes um and my view would be um you would
only
because as counselors you know lots of
people
as you're in public life the only time
you need to disclose a
non-pecuniary interest and it would be
non-pecuniary
is if you really have a very close
relationship with that person
so you would consider them to be a
really close friend
and that could have implications for you
in the sense of your relationship with
them
if you don't go in their favor or
anything of that nature so unless you
know them in a in a
close uh with a close relationship i
would say
no need to disclose
thank you very much mr quelch uh
councillor none does that answer the
question for you
difficult to define closeness isn't it
really but
uh i know two of the applicants but as
simon has said you know i guess i know a
lot of people
uh but uh i know two of them so
non-pecuniary definitely thank you thank
you very much
uh councillor stilts has your hand gone
down
are you happy with that explanation uh
yes i am thank you very much
and he was only aware of the nothing
closer than being aware of the name
thank you
thank you very much then we shall move
on to item
number five uh committee on standards in
public life we move to agenda item five
committee on standards in public life
best practices
recommendations found on pages
11 to 16. i'll just go there if i may
thank you in a moment i will call on the
lead
legal specialist and monitoring officer
to present the report
members are reminded if you wish to
speak please make this known by using
the hands up function within the meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct
mr quelch would you please present the
report
uh thank you chairman yes um members
some members on the newly composed
joint standards company may remember
this report it came
to the committee back in i think it was
october
and it's all to do with best practice
recommendations that have been sent
around
all local authorities in the country
from
what is in fact the government committee
on standards in public life
and some members will remember that we
went through some of those best
practice recommendations and the
resolution of the of the standards
committee in october was that i should
return with another report
to give any members the opportunity if
they wanted to
to make comments to me um with a view to
that
possibly influencing um what i put in
this report
i i had one member come to me
and that did tweak something i've said
in the report so the report you now have
um is with the benefit of members having
had that opportunity to come to me
and one member did and has been a slight
change to my recommendation
now back in october
and this is quite significant um
some of the issues raised in this best
practice recommendations
paper would have resulted in a change
to the local code of conduct for members
so that would have meant it would have
had to have gone to council
you could have only made a
recommendation um
particularly on the issue of a
definition of bullying and harassment
events have moved on since october and
in
december i think it was the 23rd of
december
the local government association have
now
published a brand new model code of
conduct
for members which they are hoping every
local authority
will adopt
now there are some problems with that
local
code of conduct and all the monitoring
officers in essex met together recently
and we have
major concerns about its clarity
so we have gone back to the local
government association and said you need
to tidy this up so
this the the the matters on um
bullying and harassment and defining
that um i haven't
i haven't made a suggestion for a change
of the present code because i'll be
coming back to you
with a new model code for recommendation
to counsel for adoption um hopefully
within the next six months or so so
there seems no point in
changing that while we have a new code
that's about to be um
voiced on us nationally
so perhaps chairman with your agreement
i can just go through my appendix one
and just um mention each particular best
practice point and if members want
i'll stop at each point and if a member
has a point then
they can make it are you happy with that
chairman absolutely thank you simon
okay okay going to appendix one
um best practice one says local
authorities should include prohibitions
on bullying and harassment and codes of
conduct these should include a
definition of bullying and harassment
supplemented with a list of examples
the sort of behavior covered by such a
definition and i've already mentioned
that i don't think there's any point
personally in now changing our old code
with a new one um just in the wings
i'll pause chairman at that point
members we're okay with that i i think
we're okay to carry on simon
okay thank you so sorry
best practice two councils should
include provisions in their code of
conduct requiring
councillors to comply with any formal
standards
investigation and prohibiting trivial or
malicious allegations by councillors
well actually we already have that in
our old code of conduct
paragraphs 3.4 and 3.5 and you can see
i've listed them verbatim
um in in appendix 1.
the new draft the new model code of
conduct will also have something similar
but i think the language is a bit more
concise so there's
we comply with that
okay members are we all happy to concur
with that
uh we do have counsellor nun please
simon if you wouldn't mind taking the
question
okay it's an observation really simon
you know
i agree with you about the uh the two
best practices
but there's a world of difference
between having an explicit
entry in a code and it's proper
application
chairman i agree um
particularly 3.5 i think that may be
what council anand is referring to
the making of vexatious malicious or
frivolous complaints
and that is something that i as a
monitoring officer have been
concerned about in this council
the number of complaints we had last
year was about 23
that far exceeds the average of
any council um so
i agree with councillor nun sometimes
having something in the code is one
thing actually
making that work is another
counsellor none would you like to come
back
i agree with uh simon's agreement
thank you so where does that leave us
simon
i think it means that you're you're okay
with best practice
with my response to best practice too
right okay so shall we move on then
please
best practice three principal
authorities should review their code of
conduct each year and regularly seek
where possible the views of the public
community organizations and neighboring
authorities now it is true that our code
was
last revised in 2016.
um but the with the new code coming in
hopefully in 2021 as i said obviously
that's going to be
an opportunity to up for a wholesale
revision
and the local government of association
have promised
um that they intend
to review their model code of conduct
which hopefully we shall adopt um every
year
so automatically there will be uh
a process of review
so although we haven't done that on an
annual basis
the intention is that we will triggered
by the lga
okay uh councillor civil please
thank you chairman uh mr cross in terms
of outside consultation
who who would we go and talk to yeah i
can understand the
the need to go maybe talk to another
public organization but
it says that the public or a community
organization so
to who who might we consult with that's
very difficult
um um the only one i could think of
because i thought someone might ask that
question the only one i could think of
is the citizens of vice bureau
right i i mean neighboring authorities
to be honest with you i don't see
there's a great deal of point because
we're
all basically relying on the same draft
code
the code we now have was a model code
produced by government um
back in 2014 or wherever it was
and then revised in 2016.
we are likely to be adopting the lga one
as well
so all authorities have the same code
they're looking at
i'm not quite sure why the committee on
public scrutiny have put that in
best practice three no that's what i do
it's the lack of their understanding
of how things work in local government
okay
thank you thank you and uh we now have
uh councillor boyce please
sorry chairman i'm trying to take the
hand down that's fine bob you carry on
so that's a legacy hand bob i do you
have a question i'm sorry
he's muted okay well can we come back
and that's another problem
sorry chairman that's fine do you have a
question though counselor boys
no uh um
i thought it was probably
undiplomatic to ask the question i was
going to ask so i decided not to
well that's entirely up to you but i
think we could all uh
we could all um weather a little little
diplomacy and non-diplomacy if you wish
to ask the question perhaps
you know why not
are you happy not to i'm sorry
okay all right thanks thank you council
advice can i
move to councillor stilts please
i'm afraid you're mr chairman yeah i've
just found that moot um
yeah the clue um right i think this
document should be considered as a
living document
and therefore will include instead of
can include the reason for this i've
been
involved in service organizations where
they've left it to be
reviewed at some later time and it's
gone on several years
and become out of date so i think it
should be seen every year
whether we need to make amendments or
not just to check up on that
and also with that it should have the
next review date
uh month and year inserted so it is a
trigger straight away that we know when
the next one's coming up
and can prepare any any observations we
need to make
thank you i think they're fair points uh
simon
any problems with that i mean members
could actually
resolve now when they want the next
review to be i mean i think that's
probably premature because this year
there was going to be
a wholesale look at a
new code of conduct as i said
at that particular point maybe members
will say
this is the review time we want although
as i've said the lga have promised they
are going to review it every year
okay very well is is that an answer for
you councillor stilts because i think
that's a fair point and i think we
should note that points and
thank you very much yeah thank you very
much
uh is there anyone else who would like
to speak
okay could we continue then please best
practice for
chairman is an authorities coach should
be readily accessible to both
councillors and the public
in a prominent position on a council's
website
and available in council premises now
there's two parts to this
we do have a link to the code of
uh conduct on the council's website
on the home page there is a section if
you go into it you'll see
i think counselors and you you go on to
that and that will link you through
to the code of conduct um
you may have to go through one or two
layers but as you can imagine with
in a council you can't have every single
matter and they're all important issues
as a first layer matter and it's not
possible on a website
um so it seems to me that it's it's
available if a member of the public
really wants to see what the code of
conduct says it won't take them long to
get to it
in my view um now in relation to council
premises
um prominence there is competition
first of all obviously the council
offices are not open they haven't been
open since march
but when and if they do open
um then there is competition
for prominence for lots of information
um um again i think this is
i think this is a problem of the
committee they don't really unders
they've got one thing on their minds
whereas council have
councils have many many functions that
are important
so actually to put something in a
prominent position means that something
else that perhaps might be more
important
is relegated to a non-prominent position
um
i think personally what's really
important is to have the
the code of conda readily available on
the website
and we're certainly as a local authority
along with all local authorities we are
encouraging people down the digital
route
and so that's what we should be doing
and so
that that will be my response to their
best practice for
thank you could i go to councillor
thompson please
sorry thank you chairman too many
buttons depressing
i didn't actually interpret it in quite
the same way that mr quelch has
um that the uh
it should be in a prominent position on
the website yeah i do agree with that
but it only says and available in
council premises it doesn't actually say
it should be displayed in a
prominent place in council premises okay
okay
and certainly you know anyone can walk
up
when we're open anyone can walk up to
reception and say could i have a copy
please i mean it should be that easily
available
um and perhaps on the website it should
say
obviously only when appropriate that
it's also available from
reception if anyone wants to have a look
um
but you know i'm happy with what this
says and i do agree that
especially in these times because kobe
isn't going to go away even when
the offices are open i suspect there's
going to be more important things
competing from space
thank you thank you councillor thompson
i think that's a very good comment i
think
uh i personally feel that people should
be able to go into the council offices
and absolutely see our code of conduct
as they should be able to see
any of our any of our um documents
really they should all be freely
available
and uh it shouldn't be a minefield to
find them either and i
i personally find the website
particularly difficult to negotiate
and i do think the code of conduct
should be one of those things which
should be
uh easy and accessible to everybody
so uh i think that's very good comment
uh mr quote should we continue please
yup okay best practice five
local authorities should update their
gifts and hospitality register at least
once per quarter and publish it in an
accessible format
and they use such as csv the register
held by fair my response is that the
register held by fresh service which
members will be familiar with and the
public
probably won't but it's it's um it's an
administration
service that all employees and
councillors can use to to get things
done
they raise tickets and then
administrative staff provide whatever is
necessary from that ticket so the
register is held by fresh service
and is updated um by me as soon as the
matter is declared by a councillor
so in effect this becomes a daily update
to use councillor stilts references
like a living document um now
although the public don't have automatic
access to it
they can they they can
request access to the register and that
will be provided
to to them in a form that's convenient
to them just as we would with um
a freedom of information request um
obviously we would make it more
available much quicker than a freedom of
information requests but we would
ask them what format do you want it okay
i have uh councillor hull and councillor
thompson
and uh council advice i shall go to
councillor hull first please
thank you chairman um with gifts um that
you have to
say you know register um how
what sort of gifts would you um say they
would be
like if somebody gives you a plant or
chicken or something like that or
whatever
let me just go i'm just dipping down and
i'm getting registered itself
the register itself sorry the local code
of conduct itself
deals with the issue of
um uh hospitality
and it's paragraph 11 for the for those
who like the science
and and it says that you need to notify
me
in writing of any gift benefit or
hospitality with a value in
excess of 50 pounds
which you have accepted uh as a member
so it's as a member that's really
important from any personal
body other than the authority
and then it's my responsibility to to to
ensure that that's put
on the register of gifts and hospitality
so
you've got to assess the value so a
plant
is unless it's a very um exotic plant
um is unlikely to be in excess of 50
pounds and so to the chicken
yeah so do the chicken yeah but it also
has to be given to you as a member
so say for example you've done some ward
work
for um someone living in your ward and
they're very grateful for what you've
done
so they they bring you a chicken or they
bring you a plant
that's clearly as a member but if purely
you receive a gift
generally in your life you don't have to
declare that
okay thank you thanks very much
otherwise all birthday presents will be
registerable including chickens
uh could we go to councillor thompson
please
thank you i was going to ask is the
chicken alive all day
um fancy
[Music]
um sorry to the point chairman i
apologize um
it's just a comment i'm really not at
all sure that csv
would be considered these days as a
particularly accessible
format how many of us here actually know
what csv is
i'm sure pdf would be more appropriate
but this is going to change in
with the new code anyway so just out of
interest hands up those who know what
csv
csv is yeah i thought not
thank you
[Music]
could i go to council voice please
um chairman i'm not comfortable uh with
uh with this gift hospitality
uh register been in effect
hidden from the public um
by via fresh service in my view
it should have the same relevance
as the register of interests
and should be as readily available
thank you councillor boyce uh council uh
miss mr quelch
uh could you yeah i i i certainly
understand
councillor boyce's sentiment i have a
slight reservation about that and that
in that
it's not just it's not just
the the member whose name would go
down it it would be the personal body
from whom they received it and
that concerns me that that it's just so
readily available
it is available to the public but if it
was just
available there for direct access by
anybody
i don't know that doneese have really
would really be that happy about sorry
the donor will be that happy about that
um again the public do have access
but i think it should be because they
specifically have a concern about a
particular
counsellor so they want to see what
hospitality they've received
i think it for just to be willy-nilly
available i
i don't think it's personally fair on
those
donors uh councillor boyce would you
like to come back
chairman yes um i cannot accept
um i can understand uh what mr quelch is
saying
but i i cannot accept it because there
is a contradiction there
um and the contradiction is
that if anybody wishes to dig they can
find
this information so it is therefore
available to the public
and this seems to me still to be an
attempt
to to hide from the public that a
councillor had received hospitality
in excess of um
50 pounds it may be a new car
now i don't know that the donor is is
who the donor is is relevant just the
fact that the councillor had received
such hospitality
so i think mr quelch what council boys
is saying is that
it isn't so much you know the gift we
could certainly make
public where the donor we could keep
anonymous in a fact the fact is is that
you would know that the gift had been
given
and a counselor received such a gift
is is that is that where we're going
the problem is then the register loses
a significant amount of value because
members of the public that want to
interrogate the register
may want to know who who these donors
are
um and that may be very relevant
to the gift to the council who's
received it i mean for example if
councillor a is receiving lots of
gifts from one particular person
that may be very relevant now if if you
only see the number of gifts received
but don't know who they're coming from
it's not so useful to the members of the
public
counsellor boyce i'll just come back to
you again if i may
well i can hear what council mr quelch
is saying but it just doesn't um
stack up if the public can um
uh through interrogation of our systems
find this information why withhold it
okay okay well thank you councillor
boyce i think i shall
move on from this because i think we've
sort of aired this a little bit and i do
understand where you're coming from
could i go to councillor stilts please
thank you um it's an interesting dilemma
because
if the information is so readily
available
the public have access to the council's
private details that maybe aren't
relevant now
when i was the mayor um well both times
um
i did i was possibly receiving gifts
which weren't of that that values didn't
have to be displayed
but i had uh i had an allotment i was
getting grief should we say from some of
the other
lot and holders thought it was funny so
oh well you must be getting this
you must be getting that and i think if
it had been on public display
um if it had to be um it had been even
more they they thought it was a joke but
in actual fact
after about a year it got really really
um to the point i didn't want to go to
the allotment
you know it was continuous so i think
we've got to be very careful with this
the other thing is um if it's not
displayed at all
then some councils may be tempted not to
clear anything
because they may getting feedback from
members of the public who think they're
having a laugh
thank you thank you councillors uh could
i go to councillor thompson please
um thank you steve i'm actually just
wondering and mr crouching shaw can help
us with the answer i mean are we
entitled to publish names of donors
i mean getting into gdpr territory
um that that to some extent is my
concern but the regis the
code of conduct which has the force of
law
statute um does require
uh disclosure of the gift
from any person or body now you can just
say oh that just means you put in the
gift but then it sort of to some extent
becomes of
significa it's significantly less
valuable to a member of the public just
to know that accounts has received quite
a bit but not know
the source so it seems to me to make the
get the register of gifts and
hospitality useful
you do need to say the source
um now when it the code of conduct says
the monitoring officer will place your
notification on a public register
it doesn't say how public that has to be
a register can still be public in the
sense that you
have to request the information to be
sent to you that doesn't make it not
public
if you see what i mean just simply
because there is a process
an administrative process you have to
follow to obtain the information
doesn't make it um it doesn't cease to
be a public register
okay could i go to councillor none
please
thank you chairman well call me naive
chairman but i
can't imagine why anybody would want to
accept gifts
to be honest with you apart from a pen
or something of that nature
certainly unless i misunderstood what
counselor boyce said about
a car you know i can't i can't imagine
any counsellor feeling its right to
accept a gift of that nature from a
member of the general public
if somebody offered me a rolex or a car
or something i would wonder what they
were after
and why and i know it's slightly
different for members compared with
officers
but when i was an officer we had to
declare any gifts of
calendars and pens but actually it was
up to the line manager to authorize
whether that gift could be accepted or
not
and if anybody offered me a gift i i
wouldn't accept it
or b if it was a minor one i think i'd
speak to mr quelch to say
i'm telling you i'm accepting this gift
how do you feel about that
thank you councilman and i think you're
absolutely correct i think we all
understand that if we accept
gifts such as cars chickens rolexes etc
we are opening ourselves to all sorts of
all sorts of problems
and i'm pretty sure we all are more than
aware that we would
contact mr quilt should anyone offer us
anything at all so i think we should uh
now move on please if we may jim could i
just make one point i think
would help on with your permission is
that i take
counselor nuns point but i think this is
more dealing with
where a member is invited to an event
as a member and they're given
hospitality
so there may be a hospitality tent and
just say let's just say the chairman is
invited to an event as the chairman
and it's it's a very expensive meal and
so he's offered hospitality now that
would need to be declared
i think that's that's where the register
is probably more likely to be relevant
and and again thank you scott i do think
that most of us
probably would be aware that if we were
invited and we
we were given a lavish meal or whatever
we would we would know to declare that
so uh
anyway can we move on now please yeah um
best practice six the councils
should pro publish a clear and
straightforward public interest
test against which allegations are
filtered so the allegations are where
there is a complaint made
that a member has breached the code of
conduct
at the moment i
i when a complaint is made i will
contact mr hodson as the independent
person
and we will discuss the case to decide
what is the best way to deal with it we
do not have a
published public interest test
though naturally between ourselves mr
hudson
and i take that into account and so as
we do not have a public interest test
which has been published
um i have put one in that members may
want to consider
um and i've recommended that you might
want to accept
that public interest test and put it
into the complaints procedure
information
it's based on the um
ombudsman for wales is public interest
tests when
when he has to decide whether he
investigates a complaint
and as you can see reading down the
public interest factors to be taken into
account
in his test are the seriousness of the
breach
whether the member deliberately sought
personal gain for themselves
or another person at the public expense
whether the circumstances of the breach
are such that a member has
misused a position of trust or authority
and cause harm to another
and whether the breach was motivated by
any form of discrimination
against the victims ethnic or national
origin gender disability age religion or
belief
sexual orientation or gender identity
i think the although the
three bullet points uh the three last
bullet points perhaps are more specific
the first one covers anything else
really the seriousness of the breach
so even if they're not mentioned if then
if there isn't discrimination
if there isn't um abuse of power for
example then
you can still look at the seriousness of
the breach um
and decide whether it it it's worth
being investigated
thank you members are we all happy with
that
i think we are mr coach can we move on
please so so
uh chairman is that is is that does that
would you specifically want that to
actually do members
i want that put into the complaints
procedure information
i i personally am very pleased to see
that that is there i must admit
uh so i don't know what the other
members think but
um great for thompson so
happy to propose that thank you very
much
thompson and councilman his second so
thank you very much yes please
we would okay
um best practice seven
um local authorities should have access
to at least
two independent persons we do we have
access to mr hodgson
who i have to say has been as terrific
to support
to me um i have valued his advice and
his wisdom
and he has often modified my views
and assisted me and the reserve is mr
stephen anthony who did actually step
into the breach if you recall in
relation to
a serious complaint that was made at the
beginning of last year
um because mr hudson was had a conflict
of interest
so yes we have two independent persons
thank you
okay let's move on best practice eight
an independent person should be
consulted as to whether to undertake a
formal investigation or allegation
should be given the option to review and
comment on allegations
which the responsible officer is minded
to dismiss as being without merit
vexatious
or trivial and our procedure our
complaints procedure that's in
the forms a part of the constitution
requires that i contact the independent
person
about how to progress a complaint
i think we will agreed on that one
members are we can we move on
thank you best practice nine where a
local authority makes a decision on an
allegation of misconduct following a
formal investigation
decision notice should be published as
soon as possible on its website
including a brief statement of facts the
provisions of the code engaged by the
allegation the view of the independent
person
the reasoning of the decision maker and
any sanction
and now i've applied now we do
um we we do issue decision
notices and they do go on to the website
but only where there's been a
contravention
my personal view is that it would be
wrong to put
onto the website a
decision notice which says there has
been no breach simply because
unfortunately
human nature being what it is
we always think there is no smoke
without fire even though no case has
been established and
i think personally i think it's unfair
that a a member's name should go onto a
website
uh with an allegation even though that
allegation hasn't been substantiated
in other words my view is it should only
apply to members that have breached the
code
i mean i i would agree with that uh
we've got uh councillor siddal please
yeah i would agree also with the
monitoring office there uh
yeah we should only really be publishing
things where there has been a breach
not where there's an allegation uh
because that
is the the ideal way of
of creating negative publicity um
about a situation that doesn't exist so
yeah i think we need to
to agree with the monitoring officer all
right will you do councillor
uh councillor hull please
uh you're muted councillor hull
just sorry just to say i'd agree as well
strongly
thank you councillor boyce please um
well i
i don't uh necessarily agree
um because i can remember a case
of allegations against a member that um
caused that particular person
a lot of grievance and heartache
and they wanted the their exoneration
to be published because the
um allegations had
been banned about i think even in the
press
and and then for it to suddenly go
silent
as far as the public were concerned they
believed that that was unacceptable
um so i think i think
um whether they are
that is published or not should depend
um upon um what
uh discomfort disruption
and upset had been caused to the person
that
had allegedly
been breaking the code can you thank you
counselor
i just wonder whether mr quelsh uh
is um can remember that particular case
i don't but i understand what counselor
boyce is saying and i think
um chairman my stance would be that if a
member
who had been found not guilty of
breaching the code
said to me i really want that publicized
on the website
i will just put it on okay
thank you mr welch uh could i go to we
ah there's no more hands anybody else
would like to speak
okay i think we can move on thank you
best practice 10
a local authority should have
straightforward and accessible guidance
on its website on how to make a
complaint under the code of conduct
the process for handling complaints and
an estimated time scale for
investigations and outcomes we have
all of that it is there on our website
and there is a link that provides that
information on the home page
under the section for counsellors
excellent can we move on please
best practice 11 formal standards
complaints about the conduct of a parish
council towards the clerk should be made
by the chairman
by the chair or by the parish council as
a whole rather than the clerk in all
but exceptional circumstances well my
view is that's not a matter for
the district council that's the matter
for the parishes themselves to decide
we shouldn't be dictating to the
parishes how they deal with that
i agree with that is everyone happy with
that uh
could we go to councillor stilts please
thank you mr chairman um it is a matter
for the parishes themselves and not the
district council
but um
sorry i'm looking through my notes so it
would be desirable for this to be on
each
parish stroke town standing orders as
there have been cases in the past where
the clerk
didn't report those uh who caused them a
problem
um because they're the people who
actually
do the clerk's annual review so we have
a slight uh
problem there i'd love to tell someone
but i didn't because
my this person is writes my review and
uh it's for my performance and possibly
pay off
pay increase as well that makes sense
i think it does mr crutch um
yes i mean i can if members want me to
i could send this best practice 11 to
all the
parish council clerks and they can
decide
what they want to do about it in terms
of changing their constitution
okay uh councillor thompson please
um thank you uh i certainly agree with
mr quelch that
this is not something that the um
district council should be able to
enforce
but i'm not even sure about asking them
to change their constitutions because
that doesn't that put this hypothetical
clock in an even worse position
should he or she wish to complain and
it's part of the part of their parish
council's concentric constitution that
they can only go to the last person in
the whole world they want to go to
um i i just that just troubles me a bit
i think the clerk will
to be able to be free to come straight
to wherever
and i wouldn't like to be party to
changing that thank you chairman i
actually agree with councillor thompson
i think that must be right
i i think so too actually i think that
that probably
probably makes the most sense and sort
of makes it most accessible at least
uh councillor stilts
thank you for that yeah i quite agree
i've just remembered um
ash's my wife attended as your
representative or yeah you'll see
represented
on the clarks forum so it could be
something brought to
town or town clerks via that method
instead of being put into standing
orders possibly
so they'll be aware that there is that
person they can go to
uh for help if there is a problem thank
you
thank you very much uh could we move on
please mr club
best practice 12 um
monitoring officer's role should include
providing advice support and management
of investigations and adjudications on
alleged breaches to paris councils
within the remit of the principal
authority they should be provided with
adequate training corporate support and
resources to undertake the work well i i
do do that
that's all part of my statutory role
and i also include whenever there's
training
on the local code there was back in 2019
it's due up again
um i believe uh sometime this year
in the summer of this year i invite um
parish councils to come onto that
training as well
um as far as my training is concerned
um well i i get
training as i need it um and certainly
for a new monitoring officer
then the council would obviously ensure
that they understand their particular
responsibilities
as far as parish councils are concerned
we also have two non-voting nominees
council stilts being one of them on the
committee we are still waiting from the
ealc for the replacement to councillor
anderson
and i've written to them a couple of
times saying could you please give
a second nomination but they haven't
given it to me yet
uh thank you uh mr quelch uh we have
councillor
uh bob boyce please
um uh what was the question
best practice uh 12 um
i'm talking pound chileans and pence um
now you said
um uh mr kwels that
you had a statutory duty to do this um
but does the district council
have a means of recovering costs
of the service of the uh monitoring
officer
to the parish and town councils it's
it's not allowed to chairman it's a
statutory duty
to um to deal with complaints
the district council is described in
statute as a principal council
we are the principal council for all the
parishes within the malden district
and the localism act requires that we
deal with complaints made against parish
councillors so there will be no power
to um to recharge
okay well i'd like to now move on please
if we may
uh may now uh mr quelch please best
practice 13 we are getting there
chairman um there's only
a couple more left um we've only got 15
are on to 13.
local authority should have procedures
in place to address any conflicts of
interest when undertaking a standards
investigation
possible steps should include asking the
monitoring officer
from a different authority to undertake
the investigation
every time there is a case there is
always an assessment as to whether i
or the independent person or anybody
else involved in the investigation
has a conflict and members will be aware
that on two occasions recently
because of potential conflicts of
interest we have called in monitoring
officers
from two different authorities there was
one engaged at the beginning
of last year from castle point
and another one has just been another
monitoring officer from essex county
council has been engaged in relation to
an investigation that's going on at the
moment so we are very aware of that and
actually act on it
thank you uh councillor boyce please
uh chairman um uh there is an issue with
uh with um local government acts
i believe which state that
a monitoring officer must be employed by
the authority
for which they
act as monitoring officers if we're
offloading the job
to outside monitoring officers is this
not in conflict
with the local government acts
that that is a very good question from
councillor voice all his questions are
always good
um there is an answer though and it's
found in the local government act 1972
which says that you can
anyone seconded on a project from
another
local an employee from another local
authority
is treated for the purposes of the
council's functions whatever they
are whatever is the relevant function as
an employee
of so whereas section 5
says that of the 1989 act says that the
monitoring officer has to be an
employee that is satisfied by the local
government act 72
so when we employ as we have um
employed mr turner on a particular case
because of a conflict of interest
that is ongoing is the monitoring office
of residence county council
he is therefore a second
he seconded to the local authority for
that project
therefore is treated as an employee
does that answer you uh councillor voice
of course thank you very much thank you
uh mr quotes could we move on please oh
no sorry i have uh councillor stilts
please
sorry to keep on covering these things
um
there can be a problem not so much with
the monitoring officer but where we have
joint standards
what do we hear call it being a tribunal
hearing or hearing
um there can be pressure put on i'll put
it slightly different way
right now if essex police have a
conflict of interest
then it would be kent police who come in
and vice versa
um and that's throughout the whole whole
country
the reason is it will prevent any fear
or favor
now the joint standards committee is
councillors
with fear it could be if you don't do
what we want
we will deselect you at the next
election election favor could be
we will put you up for chairperson
leader or on county
all the matter carry an increase of
financial income but more than that
perceives standing amongst their peers
so we could have a problem where
we have a say let's see if it's
definitely a serious case
where pressure can be put on um
by a member of members this is the way
we want you to vote
because and you know with the uh what
i've just said about
it so it would be more trans-bound to
the public
if we had another count not another um
council within
the district because again you know we
could put you up for district
position or not uh so they come in from
outside and it will work vice versa
as i say they police my my sister had to
do it for the the home office
um going around the different uh
constabularies
and that's the way they work so it's
completely impartial um
there can no be any accusation even from
the public that
oh well um you only voted that way or
the result was only that way because of
political pressure thank you
thank you councillor stilts could i go
to councillor none please
so that's not a monitoring officer issue
is it that's
a member issue and if
as if i understand cancer stilts
correctly
if he's saying you know uh
members would be put under pressure to
vote a particular way
a joint standards committee that would
be a very serious issue
because one of the first things i asked
when i became a district councillor
was did the whip apply uh in the case of
the joint standards committee
and the answer i was given was that that
it did not
uh and that it should not uh neither
should it with planning
so um i think that would be a very
serious issue
myself
thank you councilman uh mr quelch have
you anything to come back with
no i agree with everything that's been
said okay
okay thank you uh let's move on please
best practice 14 councils should report
on separate bodies they have set up or
which they own
as part of their annual governance
statement and give a full picture of
their relationship with those bodies
separate bodies created by local
authorities should abide
by the nolan principle of openness and
publish their board agendas and minutes
and annual reports
in an accessible place well i'm not
aware chairman of any
body that we have set up that falls
within
this best practice 14. i know we have
working groups and things like that but
i don't think that's what best practice
14 is talking about
it's talking about i believe local
authority companies
um which a lot of larger councils have
actually set up essex county council has
a whole
but has many um companies that it's
established so
that's what best practice 14 in my view
is seeking to deal with
we don't have any great thank you very
much should we take the last one please
best practice 15 senior officers should
meet regularly with political group
leaders or group whips
to discuss standards issues now there
aren't
um there aren't any
meetings that i set up on an ongoing
basis
with leaders of the political groups
but i would have ad hoc conversations as
issues arise and i
personally think that is the best way to
deal
with matters if one has um
just fixed meetings i think those can be
quite cosmetic
um whenever there is an issue relating
to a counsellor
in a political group only as required i
would speak to that leader and i have
done so
thank you and i would agree with you
thank you mr crouch any members have
any other comments to make
thank you then i shall um i shall go to
the recommendation
thank you mr crouch
uh the recommendation set out in the
report is as follows
to consider the committee on standards
in public
life best practice recommendations at
appendix one
and make any necessary changes to
standards procedures
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your microphone
and state your name
thompson council amazed thank you very
much we have councillor thompson
it's a bit of a race but we got it thank
you
if any member wishes uh if anyone has
any comments to make
further we'll go to the vote and uh
if we're all happy to vote can we agree
that
i'm assuming we're incorporating the
suggested
the wording that the monitoring officer
suggested and we all agreed while we
were there
i believe so tara is that correct
uh but yes chairman this is correct it's
banner yeah
lovely thank you very much i'm so sorry
sir that's okay no problem
first time that was recommendation six
thank you yes indeed okay so
everybody's heard that so could we agree
that by a cent
please agreed agreed agreed
thank you very much so that is agreed
uh so now we go to item number six
and this is uh to resolve sorry
is there any chance for comfort break in
five minutes
did you we all
we've got a lot of background noise we
want to go for comfort breaks are we
saying we're going to come back
and we'll come back at 15
there's 15 10 long enough or is that too
long
that's no that's fine that's seven
minutes okay members
yes promptly back here at 1510 please
thank you
absolutely thank you
one and we're live again chairman
thank you berna and hopefully we are all
back
in the room um i shall
now move to item
six on the agenda which is the exclusion
of the public
and press and this is to resolve that
under section
one zero zero a four of the local
government act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business
on the grounds that they involve the
likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph one
of part one of schedule 12a to the act
and that satisfies the public interest
test
and it's at this point uh i will say uh
thank you to the public for attending uh
we wish you
good afternoon and uh if you could now
cut the live
feed please burner